палестинське збройне угруповання хамас
проривається в Ізраїль убиває сотні
людей І розв'язує війну колишній
прем'єр-міністр Ізраїлю ехуд ольмерт
звинувачує
уряд нетаньяху має піти у відставку
так як ви думаєте він піде Йому
доведеться
пріоритет нині врятувати заручників яких
захопив хамас поки Ізраїль намагається
гарантувати безпеку своїх кордонів
постає питання чи можуть ізраїльтяни
довіряти своїй розвідці та
[музика]
арміїхуде ольмер Ласкаво просимо до
кофліктзоone
Вітаю ізраїльський державний діяч шиман
Перес часто нагадував під час інтерв'ю
що його народ живе у вкрай нестабільному
регіоні нині ситуація стала ще гіршою чи
не
так Так на жаль ми всі бачили якою
кривавою була атака хамасу на мою думку
це була одна з найжорстокіших атак за
всю сучасну історію відбувся напад на
мирне населення з явною метою вбити
Якомога більше людей найбільш страшна і
жахлива стратегія у схожий спосіб діяли
і бойовики ісламської держави оттільки у
порівнянні з іділ хамасу На жаль вдалося
досягти навіть більших
успіхів ви вважаєте що це був напад чи
можуть бути заплановані й нові можливо
не з сектору
гази не варто забувати що хамас
перебуває в постійному протистоянні з
Ізраїлем з моменту свого створення більш
як чверть століття і вони не мають
наміру заключати мир з Ізраїлем вони не
хочуть визнавати Ізраїль вони не мають
жодних конкретних територіальних
претензій до Ізраїлю як наприклад інші
палестинці на західному березі річки
Йордан вони просто хочуть знищити
державу Ізраїль на мою думку цілком
очевидно що надихає їх та керує ними
Іран вони ніби рука Ірану що сягає
далеко за його межі Іран має довгі руки
на півдні Ізраїлю - це хамас і на
півночі - це хезбола їхні Атаки є
частиною комплексного плану Ірану
спрямованого на те щоб зруйнувати баланс
на всьому близькому сході і спробувати
похитнути основи держави
Ізраїль Іран заперечує свою пряму
причетність до нападу і навіть
американці заявили що поки що не бачили
жодних доказів в цьому ви інтуїтивно
підозрюти рану причетності і нинішня
Атака була в їхніх інтересах Чи у вас є
якісь
докази розумієте Ізраїль знає про деякі
ознаки Я звісно не вдаватимуся до
подробиць Але у нас є деякі свідчення
того що хамасівців підбурював та
координував Іран за кілька днів до
нападу в лівані з візитом перебував
голова іранського корпусу вартових
ісламської революції як відомо у бейруті
також розташований штаб голови
оперативної діяльності хамасу отже є всі
підстави вважати що вони співпрацювали
та координували свої
дії
якщо це підтвердиться чи почне Ізраїль
якісь прямі дії проти
Ірану не думаю що нині у нас є якийсь
план комплексного удару по Ірану Я маю
на увазі військових із літаками ви
знаєте що ми могли б застосувати проти
Ірану нині це не є першочерговим
завданням Ми повинні зосередитися на
південному регіоні де все почалося до
тих пір звісно поки Іран не візьме пря
участі у військових діях проти держави
Ізраїль а в нинішній ситуації сумніваюся
що ми почнемо якусь атаку на
них одне питання схоже домінує ниня що
робити з десятками ізраїльських
заручників яких захопило палестинське
угруповання
хамас Як ви вважаєте як уряд
вирішуватиме цю
проблему
мушу сказати що я не впевнений що маю
відповідь і якби навіть знав я не хотів
би зараз публічно ділитися цим і з
кимось включаючи вас тому що йдеться про
життя або смерть людей якщо хамас був
здатний ґвалтувати матерів а потім
убивати їх вбивати дітей у їхніх же
будинках то вони без жодних вагань
вчинять найжорстокіші дії щодо
ізраїльтян яких вони зараз тримають у
заручниках у секторі гази Ізраїль звісно
діятиме сумніваюся що з хамасом можна
вести переговори Бо насправді вони їх і
не бажають адже вони хочуть звільнити
всіх палестинських ув'язнених які
утримуються в Ізраїлі а ізраїльтян які
потрапили до них у заручники спробують
використати для торгів якою буде наша
реакція як ми впораємося з цим Які
заходи Ми плануємо Які сюрпризи готуємо
думаю це не те що слід обговорювати
публічно
якби ви були при владі ви пішли б на
угоду з хамасом адже угоди вже
укладалися у минулому були обміни
полоненими у 2011 році в обмін на
повернення додому солдата ділада шаліта
було звільнено понад 1ся
палестинців ні моя відповідь ні І це
була моя відповідь коли я був
прем'єр-міністром у той час коли я був
прем'єром в обмін на гілада шаліта мені
було запропоновано набагато Скажімо так
кращу угоду і я від неї відмовився Я
вважав що вкладати її не варто що вона
цього не варта І до речі треба пам'ятати
Я не впевнений що ви в курсі все
керівництво хамасу сьогодні все
керівництво хамасу Яке несе
відповідальність за те що вони вчинили
проти нас ізраїльтян у суботу 7 жовтня
складається з колишніх ув'язнених які
були тоді звільнені в рамках угоди щодо
гілада
шаліта виходить що коли ця угода була
укладена відбувся обмін понад ся
екстремістів на одного солдата Я вважаю
що в довгостроковій перспективі
результати цієїгоди стали справді
руйнівними для Ізраїлю і ми повинні бути
вкрай обережними щодо форматів в яких
укладаються подібні угоди Але це не
означає що способів звільнити ізраїльтян
яких вони утримують не існує Утім знову
ж таки як я вже сказав це слід
вирішувати дуже обережно і
непублічно
пане ольмерт було багато розмов про
системні провали в роботі ізраїльської
розвідки які призвели до цього нападу
але ви звинувачуєте в цьому уряд ви
назвали це результатом самовпевненості
нинішнього уряду самовпевненості щодо
чого якщо дозволите я скажу вам дві речі
перше гадаю що було б помилкою вважати
що ізраїльська розвідка зазнала
цілковитої поразки так можна вважати Але
це буде помилкою Зовсім ні ми все бачили
Ми спостерігали за всіма приготуваннями
і все це збіглося один в один з тим що
ми моніторили і помічали і аналізували
протягом тривалого часу проблема полягає
в тому що ми самі себе ввели в оману що
вони цього не зроблять через те що ви
процитували через самовпевненість і
зарозумілість хто вони такі хамас ці
терористичні організації вони не армія
вони ні на що не здатні вони нас не на
то турбують вони не підуть на це адже ми
сильні і могутні ми можемо зупинити їх
усіх насправді за кілька днів до свято
сукот яке було в суботу 7 жовтня так
співпало того дня ми вивели кілька
військових підрозділів з позиції на
кордоні сектором гази для захисту наших
поселенців на західному березі річки
Йордан це було відображення тієї
байдужості самовдоволення та
зарозумілості які як на мене
характеризують дії нинішнього
ізраїльського керівника
у з'язку з ми подіями саме тому я
покладаю провину на ізраїльське
керівництво справа ще й в тому що
протягом певного часу протягом багатьох
років нетаньяхо явно вважав за краще
мати справу з хамасом щоб не мати справи
з палестинською національною
адміністрацією Чому Тому що він не хотів
вести мирні переговори з палестинською
національною автономією і тому доклав
усіх зусиль для того щоб налагодити
певний контакт з хамасом ми знаємо що ма
протягом багатьох років фінансувався з
відоми Ізраїлю сотнями мільйонів доларів
які надходили з катору за сприяння
держави Ізраїль за повної
поінформованості про це та підтримки з
боку ізраїльського уряду на чолі з
беньяміном нетаньяху нетаньяху прийшовши
до влади у 2009 році заявив що головним
його обов'язком Та пріоритетом є
знищення хамасу але протягом усього
періоду його прем'єрства він докладав
усіх можливих зусиль для того щоб цього
не робити а навпаки сприяв зміцненню
хамасу і певною мірою розширення та
зміцнення хамасу - це теж результат
політики
нетаньяху пане ольмарт Ізраїль може
увійти до гази з метою викорнити хамас
та знищити якнайбільше його бойовиків
але до чого це призведе адже Ізраїлю не
вдасться провести цю операцію без втрат
чи не
так Я думаю що по-перше хамас - це ворог
і з ним треба боротися Як це зробити
намагатися здійснити вторгнення за
допомогою наземних сил як ми це робили в
минулому не знаю я не хочу вступати в
такі дискусії можу лише сказати що Це
довга історія вона вимагатиме часу Вона
вимагає дуже ретельного планування та
дуже продуманих дій і зробити це
потрібно таким чином щоб отримати
практичні результати які будуть
корисними для безпеки пів
частини держави Ізраїль і водночас не
відштовхнути від Ізраїлю міжнародне
співтовариства Яке нині дуже прихильно
налаштоване щодо Ізраїлю боюся що якщо
ці удари яких завдає цахал останніми
днями продовжуватимуться і дедалі більше
будівель у газі руйнуватимуться дим і
вогонь транслюватимуться на всіх
телеканалах щодня по всьому світу то
скоро емоції співчуття які зараз
відчуваються у всьому світі щодо Ізраїлю
зміняться А ми побуємо такої підтримки
щоб мати змогу досягти реалізації
стратегічних інтересів нашої
країнин міжнародне співтовариство вже
висловило занепокоєння щодо тотальної
блокади сектору гази перекриття доступу
до електрики води продовольства А ви
пішли б на такий
крок не хочу говорити про що я зробив би
я вже казав що можу лише говорити про те
чого б я не зробив але скажу вам таке
гуманітарний тиск може бути й розумним
засобом його можна застосувати для того
щоб провести межу між цивільним
населенням яке не залучено до діяльності
бойовиків і власне терористичними
організаціями але одна з проблем з якою
ми стикаємося в цьому контексті відносна
гнучкість і Свобода якою користується
хамас у газі бо цивільне населення яке
навіть Необов'язково залучене до
терористичної діяльності надає йому
підтримку як це розділити Це питання чи
можна це зробити в такий спосіб я
недостатньо залучений до ухвалення
рішень в уряді щоб відповісти на це
питання але не виключають цього
чи має нетаніяхо піти у
відставку так як ви думаєте він піде він
буде змушений це займе якийсь час
звіснозна що для такого роду реакції у
суспільстві зазвичай треба набрати
певний імпульс перш ніж вони зможуть
проявити себе і тоді їх уже не зупинити
нетаньяху це вже минуле з ним покінчено
він ще деякий час буде прем'єр-міністром
Але він уже не жилець в політиці і на
тей є вагомі причини
те що вчинив хамас за масштабами
відрізняється від того що терористи
робили раніше Як ви вважаєте Чому вони
розпочали таке вторгнення і чому саме
зараз існує дуже поширена думка що тим
самим Вони хотіли зірвати мирну угоду
між Ізраїлем та саудівською аравією яка
посилила в ізоляцію палестинців Як ви
гадаєте це могло стати причиною того що
відбулося таке пояснення має право на
існування не знаю чи правда це і я не
маю даних розвідки які б могли
підтвердити що це те що було на думці у
палестинців щодо цього можу сказати дві
речі якщо вони хотіли зірвати угоду між
США саудівською аравією та Ізраїлем То
наразі Вони точно досягли певного успіху
складно судити про долю цієї угоди Але я
не думаю що вони це зробили бо вважали
що палестинці залишаться осторонь цієї
угоди можливо навпаки вони побоювалися
що внаслідок цієї угоди може виникнути
основа яка змусить ізраїльський уряд
вести переговори з палестинською
національною автономією а хамас
переговорів не хоче Ви маєте зрозуміти
найлютішим ворогом хамасу є потенційний
мир між Ізраїлем і палестинцями Отже
якщо угода Саудівської Аравії США та
Ізраїлю якимось чином підвищувала шанси
на деякі контакти між ізраїльським
урядом та палестинською національною
автономією між нетаньяху Та махмудом
абасом то це й становило для них головну
загрозу це те що вони хотіли зруйнувати
тому що їх не хвилюють що палестинці
залишаться осторонь навпаки вони хочуть
щоб палестинці залишилися осторонь бо
Саме цей робить хамас привабливим для
палестинського
населення ви завжди підтримували ідею
двох держав але не змогли її реалізувати
коли були прем'єр-міністром хоча цього
тижня ви сказали що вже давно уклали б
мир з махмудом аббасом чи не думаєте Ви
що про концепцію двох держав можна
забути ні ні дивіться іншого рішення
просто не існує є лише концепція дві
держави для двох народів або концепція
про єдину державу концепція єдиної
держави означатиме що Ізраїль має стати
двонаціональною державою і мільйони
палестинців житимуть на території
Ізраїлю навіть якщо ізраїльські міністри
консерватори будуть проти цього і ті
частини ізраїльського населення які їх
підтримують теж виступатимуть проти
неминуче доведеться надати всім
палестинцям Які житимуть на території
Ізраїлю повні права політичні права
право участі у виборах тощо це створить
жахливе протистояння у суспільстві і
може призвести до набагато страшніших
злочинів ніж ті які ми бачили у суботу 7
жовтня бо тоді вони будуть у складі
держави частиною держави Ізраїль з
одного боку у них будуть політичні
голоси та право впливати на державу а з
іншого Свобода робити все що вони хочуть
робити на противагу державі Ізраїль адже
вони не хочуть бути частиною держави
Ізраїль вони хочуть мати свою власну
незалежну державу та реалізувати своє
право на самовизначення тому я думаю що
концепція однієї держави для ізраїльтян
і палестинців - це найгірший кошмар
єдина альтернатива яка може принести
певну стабільність у довгостроковій
перспективі це концепція двох держав не
одразу звісно не за кілька років
знадобиться час обом сторонам буде дуже
важко забути про 55 чи 60 років окупації
але це єдиний
варіант дуже коротко у нас лишилося
обмаль часу наскільки вам наразі страшно
за свою
країну я не боюся за країну Ізраїль дуже
сильна країна У нас неймовірно сильне
громадянське суспільство неймовірно
сильне І абсолютно вір в силу рішучість
ентузіазм та відданість які виявляють у
ці дні усі верстви населення Я боюсь
ізраїльського уряду боюся цієї групи
головорізів жорстоких
ультраортодоксальних бандитів яких
очолює безрозсудна безвідповідальна
людина нетаньяху який керує державою
Ізраїль Ми повинні позбутися їх і ми
повинні позбутися хамасу спочатку хамас
а потім ми повинні будемо навести лад у
державі
Ізраїль
льмер щиро дякую за участь у програмі
конфліктзон
[музика]
[оплески]
дякую
than